Dois homens começaram a operar Bitcoin exatamente no mesmo dia.
Um passava 12 horas por dia vidrado na tela,
tentando desesperadamente surfar cada alta.
Mas ontem à noite, uma única "armadilha de baleia"
liquidou todas as economias da vida dele.
E o outro homem? Ele jantou com a família,
dormiu tranquilo e acordou com um lucro de 5 mil dólares.
A diferença não foi sorte. Foi o sistema.
Um foi o "alvo", o outro se tornou o "estrategista".
Muitos falham porque jogam o jogo das baleias.
Eles compram quando são induzidos a comprar,
mas quando há uma armadilha, você é apenas a presa.
O Trap Defence BTC muda o jogo
ao visualizar o que está oculto no mercado.
Nosso motor detecta a manipulação institucional
antes que ela destrua o seu saldo (PnL).
Nós te damos a habilidade suprema: a disciplina
para manter seu capital seguro até a vitória ser sua.
Esta é a estratégia de elite para sobreviver
em um mercado de alto risco.
E hoje, você pode se equipar totalmente grátis.
Entre na Academy agora e receba a
"Minimum Edition" do Trap Score de presente.
Sem cartão, sem enrolação.
Apenas a verdade nua e crua do mercado.
Pare de ser a presa, torne-se quem domina o jogo.
Clique abaixo para iniciar o bot
e garanta seu acesso gratuito agora mesmo.
Comece agora.
Acesse aqui.